This is my favorite subject.
I spent 15 years
of my life building
UIs in the traditional
event handler way.
It just felt so, so hard that
it was almost offensive to me,
that I should need to use every
single ounce of my brainpower
to hold in my head this pretty
small dialogue in a Windows
app.
It's not the most complicated
thing in the world.
And yet I am straining
all of my brain cells
to make sure that all these
relationships are correct.
It seems like everything you
add makes it exponentially more
complicated.
That's exactly right.
All nontrivial software, this
is the number one problem,
how do we manage the complexity,
because everything we add
has the potential to interact
with everything else.
So what I want to say about
this reactive graph issue,
where you start out with
an input and an output,
not even a reactive
in the middle.
Just input, output, multiple
inputs to one output,
multiple outputs to one input.
Sure.
All of that is pretty
understandable.
And then you add one or
two reactive calculations
in the middle.
But it doesn't
take much for that
to start becoming
very crazy-looking,
especially when you
have multiple levels
of reactive calculations.
I think the most important
thing to understand
is that you're not supposed
to understand the whole graph.
The goal is not to create
a graph that you look at
and say, oh, that's
definitely right.
Think of this as
the same exact thing
with functions in a
normal piece of software
or a normal package.
Which functions call
which other functions?
And you can draw
a graph with that.
You can draw a function
[? called ?] graph.
And people do.
There's software that
does that for you.
It helps you make
those connections.
The goal is never
to be able to look
at that entire
graph of functions
pointing at each other and
be like, oh, yep, it's right.
That's not the point.
If your software
is well-written,
the point is to be able to look
at any one node in that graph
and prove to yourself
that that node is correct,
to look at one
output and just look
at the things that are calling
in to that output, just one
level.
Don't go beyond the arrows
that are going directly
into that output and
say, are those correct?
And if the answer is yes,
then you can move on.
You can move on to look
at each of the other nodes
in the graph.
So the point is not to be
able to reason globally.
The point is to be
able to reason locally.
This is exactly the same thing
that we say about functions.
When you write a
function, the goal
is not to be able to take the
entire rest of your code base
that might indirectly
or directly call
or be called by a function
that's under the question.
The goal is to be able
to look at this function
and to be able to confidently
say if the functions that this
calls are written correctly,
then this logic is correct.
So you need to be able
to look at this function
and reason about just this
function in isolation.
Now, you might be wrong.
You might be assuming that
those other functions are
written correctly.
And that might not be true.
But that problem is
a much better problem
to have to tackle
than the possibility
that all those functions
are correctly written,
and you still don't know
if your code is correct,
because not only do you have
to know that they're correct,
but you have to know about
really subtle interactions
that those functions
have with each other.
With reactivity, this is a way
that same quality of, I can
look at a small piece of code.
And just by knowing
that the reactives that
are being called--
just assume that those are going
to execute at the right time.
Then this is going to
execute at the right time.
If there is something
that I'm calling
and I don't want to
update when it updates,
then I need to know to
call isolate around that.
So not calling
isolate when I don't
want a reactive
relationship, that
would be a bug in this code.
But if I don't have that
bug, if my relationship
with my immediate things
that I depend on is correct,
then I'm satisfied that this
piece of code is correct.
And now I can go look
at another piece of code
and make sure that it's correct.
The bottom line being if you
have an app that's written out
of 10 such pieces
of code, then you
have to make sure that 10
pieces of code are correct.
And if you add an
11th piece of code,
you have to make sure
that 11th piece of code
is correct as opposed
to having to make sure
that each piece of code and all
of the possible interactions it
could ever have with any
of the rest of the pieces.
Now, that's not 10
things you need to check.
It's 10 factorial or
something like that.
Or I don't know
what the math is.
But it is something
that's certainly
nonlinear in terms of each
additional thing you add.
You now have to check
all the possible things
that it could interact with.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm going to add a new thing.
And it's going to
be so complicated
to know whether this is
going to blow up something
that I already have.
That was the world
that we lived in
before we reactivity
when it came
to writing interactive UIs.
This might go nowhere.
But I think when people think
about the LEGO analogy, which
that comes up a
lot when you talk
about components and software.
A lot of people think
of them as LEGOs.
At a high level, you
tend to think, oh,
I want the ability
to snap anything.
Anything should be able
to snap to anything else.
I just want to take
two software components
and snap them together.
I don't get that much
pushback on reactivity.
Like, oh, why didn't you
do reactivity this way?
There just has not
been that much of it.
I think because it's
sufficiently complicated
that it's not the most
natural thing to bikeshed on.
But modules are the opposite.
Everybody has got an
opinion on modules.
And I mean, for most
of the life of Shiny,
people have had opinions on why
I didn't do it the right way,
and the right way
meaning something
so different to every person.
But one really common
refrain was, basically,
people don't like that
you have to pass in.
If you have something
like a module
that takes some
kind of input that
needs to be provided from
somewhere else on the app--
you've got a module that does
something with a data frame.
But it doesn't
itself want to have
any opinion about what that data
frame is or where it came from
or how it specified.
It wants to specialize just
on some output or whatever.
How do you communicate
with that module?
How do you tell it this is
the data frame you should use
and here's when it changes?
And the way that
works in Shiny modules
is when you define
the module, you
take that data
frame as an input.
You take a reactive
calculation as an input.
A lot of people
push back on that.
And they're like, I don't
want to have all these things
that I'm passing
into this LEGO brick.
Why can't all LEGO bricks
just look the same?
I don't want to pass in these
four arguments that it needs.
I just want to give
it a dictionary.
How about that?
Every module just
takes a dictionary.
And then you just have
to put the right things
in the dictionary
and then look how
clean the code is for snapping
together all these LEGOs.
I just make a dictionary,
put some stuff in it,
and then everybody
gets the dictionary.
And, oh, I can
use the dictionary
for both input and output.
Not only can I get
data frames out
of it or other reactive things,
I can also push values into it.
And then other modules
can consume it.
And look how easy it is to
snap these LEGOs together.
This is where it's not enough
that the LEGOs go together.
They have to go
together correctly.
So LEGO minifigs have
heads and torsos and legs.
You can't put a head
on the legs directly.
They only connect one way.
And those connections
are obvious.
With a lot of components,
it's actually more like that.
You don't want LEGOs that will
snap together, whether they
belong together or not.
You actually want it
to be very obvious
that this thing needs to
connect with something
that's like this.
It's more like puzzle pieces.
So people arguing
for, oh, let me just
have a dictionary that I pass
in, what they're really saying
is like, oh, it's so
annoying putting together
this puzzle with all the
pieces are all jagged.
Wouldn't it be easier if
they were all just squares?
Let me put together
this 500-piece puzzle.
But it'll be so much easier
if they're all just squares.
You're actually
making it so much
harder because that
problem still exists.
You still need to make sure that
that data frame that you need
is provided to you.
It's just now provided
in a very hidden way
that you have to go speak out.
That's not obvious.
So you've removed the signal
of how these things connect.
You've removed these sort
of weirdly shaped borders
and replace them
with flat borders,
even though they can
really still only connect
in one way that makes sense.
So, again, just another
example of that principle
of small pieces that we can
locally reason about and then
combine them in reliable ways.
And when we have just
like these dictionaries
that we pass around, it's
removing that part of,
we need to be able to
combine these reliably.
There's so many different ways
I want to answer this question.
Certainly, between building
the front end and the back end,
I don't think there's
a right order.
If what is going to get you
excited about the project
enough to build that momentum
is that you have this cool UI
concept in mind or
that just motivates you
to look at something concrete
and see it sort of one piece
after another light
up, absolutely
go crazy with the UI first.
I don't think there's
anything wrong with that.
If, instead, you really
have some kind of R code
on the server that you're really
excited to see come to life
for the first time
and that is going
to be what excites
you and propels you
through the rest
of the project, I
don't think that there
is a wrong way to do it.
If you want to end
up with this a bunch
of well-named, well-reasoned
nicely factored reactives
and outputs and whatever,
is that something you
do on a whiteboard first
and then stub each one out
and make it so?
Or is it more something
that you just start coding
and then extract out the
things that you need?
Again, I don't think there's
a wrong way to do it.
But I would draw
a direct analogy
to when you're writing
either a package or maybe
a complicated script.
When and how do you
introduce functions?
Because it's exactly
the same process that
applies here as well, I think.
Maybe it's a little bit more
urgent because it's not going
to react unless you find
somewhere to park this code
that is [? in ?] [? reactive. ?]
So in that sense,
you are going to be
forced to confront it.
But some people might write
straight-line code that's--
I'm just going to get
this thing working.
I'm going to get
the answer I want.
And then let me take
a step back and see
where are opportunities
to refactor
and turn into functions.
I think that's probably
the most common.
And for that reason,
you might go a long time
without ever learning
how to write functions
if your job is more about
finding that answer the one
time and then moving on.
So I would call that sort
of a bottom-up approach.
You've got the logic,
and then now you're
trying to extract
structure out of it.
I think that's probably the
more common way people think,
their brains work.
I happen to be the other way.
Whereas I will start with--
if I could wave a magic wand
and have whatever
functions I need
to exist if they could exist,
what little piece of code
would I write that would solve
the problem that I have here?
So for some really simple
example, I might say I want--
I'll wave my magic wand
and say load data set,
remove outliers, and clean.
Maybe that's another function.
And then let me generate a
set of outputs using these two
functions that I wish existed.
And I will just call them
even though they don't exist,
and then I will stub them out.
So that's working
exactly the opposite way.
I'm calling functions
that don't exist.
And then each of those
functions is potentially
going to call
functions that don't
exist until,
eventually, they start
calling functions that exist.
And then you basically create
a skeleton for the structure
first and then fill out, go back
and fill out all the pieces.
If you can get to this place
either way of small components
that you can individually
reason about and combine them
reliably, that's
ultimately what matters.
So, yeah, in this second--
the top down way where you
call the function that you wish
existed, making sure that that
they're functions that you
want to be, well, functional.
You tend to want them not
to use global state if you
can help it.
I guess in the
Python world, there
might be classes that
you wish existed.
You [? knew ?] [? of ?] an
object that doesn't exist yet.
You call methods
that don't exist.
And then you can go back
and fill those things out.
It is harder to do the top down
if it's an unfamiliar domain.
I think the more speculative
and the more like, oh,
my gosh, how is this
even going to work,
the harder it is to go
that top-down approach.
So I'll sometimes go
the top-down approach
until I realize, oh, I'm
way out over my skis here.
I don't actually know how to
have this technology works.
Let me go back and do a bunch
of bottom-up experiments
and just work with these
libraries I've never
worked with or this kind of data
that I've never seen before.
And once you start to
get a sense of confidence
about how the problem
is going to be solved,
then I might switch
over to, OK, let
me go back to this
approach of top down.
So the same thing, I
think, for Shiny apps.
I tend to think top down.
So if I'm looking at a
dashboard that I want to build
and it's going to have
these four inputs, I think,
what data am I going
to need for that?
Oh, I'm going to have to
do a bunch of aggregations
in order to get that data.
Do I also need to access
the unaggregated data
for other things in the app?
Well, if so, then I
really want to make sure
that those are both
things that are
exposed as not functions in this
case but reactive calculations.
And then I feel like the
relationship between the inputs
and the reactive calculations,
I tend not to even think
about that at all.
That just sort of happens.
I call the things that I need.
And then they end
up depending on them
unless there's some very
specific reason like, I'm
going to use this slider input
to inform this calculation,
but not till this
button is pressed.
OK, fine.
Then you use an event for that.
I can't relate sometimes
when people say to me like,
oh, there's all these
problems with my reactivity,
and I have a really
hard time keeping
track of what inputs are being
referenced by what reactive.
I'm sort of like, why do
you need to keep track?
It's not about keeping
track of the global graph.
So it's really about
each individual reactive
only accessing the
things that it needs.
That's the way I approach it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]